c'est quoi l'histoire du servette était
en train de manger à mon couscous
mulimbi du du maine j'essaie toujours
cette montpetit saïd cedac l'assaba
'pharmas' et là je fais je fais comme
tout un chacun je vais là-bas ouais
j'étais avec la dalle dame script de
andré téchiné et à dia le patois diallo
père de copia puis je fais mon demi tour
messieurs en la ligne blanche a créé la
voiture et rouge jeudi jc pas vrai alors
là ils reconnaissent les dix poids dans
la balance à peser sur le web le casque
imai
il faut souffler le mans vous avez vu ce
que vous avez fait je dis oui je le fais
toujours à fabriquer mais il ya le feu j
y avait personne je peux m'amuser à
passer devant une bagnole qui va
m'écraser j'ai pas la souplesse d'avant
donc alors je dis bah fait quoi souffler
à bas contre surprise j'avais 0,29
ouais et la 0,25 mais oui mais ça se
savait pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
java
ça passe c'est une salade très bien
écrit
[Rires]
sous la main pour la santé bien sûr et
donc oui donc ils te disent oui il dit
scott mais en vain j'ai dit donnez moi
un autre estime être un éthylotest
l'éthylotest
alors on va dans le mur il y avait un
jeune tunisien très sympathique des des
flics impeccable gentil il y avait deux
russes comme par hasard ça assez grave a
dit pas tout ce qui est dit là il y
avait deux russes et opal j'ai dit oui
jeudi met donc on parle comme ça j
-louis j'aime beaucoup la russie je mets
tous à son commissariat tout ça au
commissariat une soirée au commissariat
on est occupé un peu comme gainsbourg
faisait là c'est 2,3 que ça y est
ensemble frais et donc ouais c'est ça et
donc après je souffle et là je tombe
0,27 à nous à retiens je reste 10
minutes de plus si jamais c'est ça oui
bon mais en fait beau ils vous ont dit
tu peux pas repartir en de obligé s'il
n'y a pas de problème quand le garde le
scooter sur le trottoir j'avais à
quelqu'un de chercher voilà on va le
mettre
c'est un mouvement tahri qui l on parie
qu'on a mis mon amour lavalard hymne
d'amour
et puis dont je vois le lendemain c'est
là où je voulais dire que toi tu tendent
et en sort très bien tu te débrouilles
avec sa magnifique mans parce que ces
[ __ ] de comment ça s'appelle des
soviets berg la piste pas des réseaux
sociaux
c'est ce qui vient earl et ôte tes
mensonges un plus et je lui en plus
c'est les flip est ce que c'est vrai que
quoi que ce soit et pas du tout sur les
réseaux hta pas dit non mais je ne
démissionne pas loin ma recette sous lé
nom puisqu avait piétiné de téléphone
j'ai un téléphone chinois
ah ouais je déteste apple
c'est vrai que tu déteste tout ce qui
vient des états unis ah oui bon il
paraît qu'on m'a dit on peut lui servir
tout ce que tu veux mais pas don
d'organes un plus bas d'amérique pas
d'américains at il dit les américaines
louis le gentil week-end sa mère est pas
d'amérique alors non non666 vient
tourner et john malkovich est un super
pote à toi magnifique moins batailleur
il le fait une tournée avec moi de motos
puissantes souvient il en parle là
dessus pour aller voir johnny était
aussi arrêt était parti très loin cas